this video is sponsored by surf shark
the Jaya and Skype yarks have some of
the most insane and intense world
building I have ever experienced and not
just that also has one spectacularly
written story from beginning to end in
this video I will be covering once again
the largest section of the manga I've
read to date over 85 chapters soaring
through some of the most awe-inspiring
and wondrous adventure arcs the tale of
one piece has yet woven offering more
world building character introductions
and story than any other arc has offered
in the past high praise for sure and
today's the day I spread my wings to
cover this incredibly massive tale of
adventure honesty and tragedy my name is
Tony nut mark and these are my first
impressions my thoughts on and review
for the most immersive and fun story
I've experienced on this review series
to date this is the ambitious mysterious
and extraordinary sky pious son
[Music]
through my reading of this section as
well as putting my feelers out to get an
idea of what you guys think of this
particular arc online a particular
divide so to speak regarding this story
of sky Pia has come to my attention
apparently there's a portion of people
that really don't like this arc and
consider it slow or bloated and after
having finished at myself in the manga I
can say that I personally didn't
experience that and in this video I will
be explaining in excruciating detail why
my journeys through the skies of one
piece were as enjoyable as they were but
in the interest of complete transparency
I've been told that the anime in this
section is much slower in comparison to
the manga but I can't really confirm
this either as I personally haven't
watched the anime section myself so in
this video even though I'm sure there
will be those of you out there who might
not necessarily agree with me from the
outset I'm going to do my best to
explain my rationale behind every
opinion I share in this video and boy
let me tell you after reading all this
I've got some weird theories swirling
around in my head too but more on that
later
[Music]
Jaya chapters 218 to 236 the story of
the sky pious saga can be broken up into
two sections or arcs the first being
jaya and the second being sky piya which
the saga itself is named after and guys
i know in the last video covering
alabasta i was overwhelmed with the
amount of stuff in that arc but this
this is like that only on steroids once
again each year oda went above and
beyond the call of duty here in crafting
a world that needs to be experienced in
order to fully appreciate it unlike the
alabasta saga which felt as though it
had several segments as self-contained
stories prior to its finish in the arcs
like little garden and drum island sky
pious saga is composed entirely of one
solid story that flows perfectly from
beginning to end incorporating two
separate arcs which personally makes
this by far and away my favorite saga in
this series to date and as soon as the
story kicks off it becomes abundantly
obvious how ambitious this tale is going
to be even with the minor set pieces
that are being placed as before the crew
even land on
tropical island of jaya they see some
crazy things like 200 year old ships
falling from the sky Luffy's discovery
of a map that illustrates this secret
land of Skype yet their log pose
pointing straight up into the air and
what looks like massive Giants trotting
across the ocean before them not to
mention freak storms that come out of
nowhere but moreover this sense of
adventure and longing to see a thought
to be mythical land is what drives the
first half of this story however unable
to find their way to the sky itself a
storm forces them to the island of jaya
and when they're the panelling and
composition of the introductory chapters
in this manga are absolutely without
exception stunning and my favorites from
the entire series through the
environment of the island we are
introduced to the culture customs and
people there and once on the island the
gang are greeted sometimes well and most
of the time awfully by the pirates that
take refuge there also and of the
characters we do meet during this time
there are three during this joyous
section that I think are worth
mentioning is I believe them to be
somewhat important to either this saga
alone or to the future of this series
let's start off small with the character
of Bellamy a blowhard pirate that has a
bazaar in somewhat obsessive desire to
squash the dreams of others but despite
his in hindsight less than impressive
showing in the arc he actually managed
to facilitate some wonderful aspects of
the giant story that honestly kept it
interesting for me proving a wonderful
opportunity for Luffy to demonstrate his
growth as a character echoing red haired
shanks from the first chapter of the
manga as Luffy Azzaro show restraint
against his brutality that ultimately
towards the end of the era comes to a
head as we finally get to see Luffy
completely outclassed and crushed this
no-good dream crusher but perhaps the
most important aspect of this character
was his fixation on bounties I had never
really paid much attention to bounties
in the past as they hadn't played that
larger role in the story up until now
but the way this conflict between
Bellamy and Luffy hinged heavily on the
bounty mechanic I thought it worth
mentioning now the notion of reputation
or bounties are a surprisingly robust
plot device in this series I found while
I've been warned to not compare bounties
to Dragon Balls power level system I
think from a narrative point of view
they share some obvious similarities but
largely are distinct to them and more
importantly I think they are much better
so let me explain
unlike Dragon Balls power level system
that primarily focuses on power
output or strength for lack of a better
term while a bounty can incorporate that
it certainly isn't just limited to that
more broadly it indicates how notorious
a particular individual is how much
they've gotten away with their ability
or their influence is included in this
also it's much more versatile than
simply stating they are strong it adds
an air of mystery to that individual as
technically speaking they don't
necessarily have to be strong in order
to have a high bounty but what makes a
bounty in this particular instance
similar to Dragon Balls power level
mechanic was its implementation during
this jaya arc with Bellamy who was
fixated on Luffy's outdated bounty
reward of 30 million berries and thought
because his bounty was higher he could
easily squash him remind you of anything
from dragon ball in the same way that
the fungal infected from the last of us
are different from the undead zombies
they are based on they both can be used
to achieve the same effect mechanically
within a story and when the author so
chooses can be used differently also in
this instance the one piece bounty
mechanic despite being different to
power levels on a technical level was
used the exact same way to create the
same effect in this particular story for
the villain to underestimate the hero
and for that hero then to shatter his
expectations take him out with ease it's
a tremendous scene and it made me really
think about how bounties could be used
in the future now the second character
I've arbitrarily labelled as worth
mentioning is Blackbeard his reveal man
was freaking awesome and totally took me
by surprise so first things first the
first time we see him he gives off the
impression of being a regular pirate
that happens to share the same
philosophies as the rest of the straw
hats but later when it's revealed to be
Blackbeard himself
it made my hand spin because now I don't
know what to trust anymore
could Goldie Roger still be alive so
many questions with virtually no answers
yet in this story oh and before I move
on to the most important character in
this arc we do also get to see an
extremely important council of world
officials and two new warlords of the
sea I can't really say much about this
scene other than that it's a very clear
example that they're setting the stage
for what's to come in the ax to follow
after this and that's something older
hasn't received enough credit from me
for if you cash your minds back to my
review of alabasta some of the most
impressive surprises came from seeds
that were planted arks prior and with
the likes of Blackbeard in these fine
gentlemen I'm
sure this is very much the case here
also the final character worth talk
about in this arc is cricket I wanna be
treasure hunter living in literally half
of a house on the edge of the giant
island explained to be a descendant of a
notorious liar called Noland who four
hundred years prior claimed that he and
his crew landed on and discovered Jaya
which supposedly housed the City of Gold
El Dorado and despite having returned a
number of years later unable to locate
this lost city of El Dorado until the
day came when he was called for his
execution he never once claimed to have
lied about a single thing always
claiming that the sound of a wonderful
Bell led him to the shore of the island
and that honest was a massive city of
gold and these events surrounding the
curious mystery of this man's claims led
his descendant cricket dedicate his life
searching the seabed for what he thought
was the treasure of El Dorado and that's
essentially going to be the driving
force behind Luffy and the gangs journey
to find sky Pia hoping to make sense of
the real left behind by Noland stating
the El Dorado stands in the right eye of
the skull
I feel like Jaya and Skype he provides
so much in the way of world building
that there's not a single chance in hell
I'll be able to pick up on everything I
mean I haven't even touched on the
massive jet of war that randomly shoots
out of the seat that they locate using a
bird that only points south which
catches them and sends them flying all
the way to Skype here from a pursuing
captain Blackbeard like that's a whole
lot of stuff that I can't even get into
right now but to succinctly boil it down
while having a nice self-contained story
and confident that finds its resolution
with Bellamy the primary reason Jaya
exists is to introduce us to the
motivations and setups for the arc that
follows while also establishing some
geography pecking orders and Wildlife
but that's enough of Jaya it's time to
soar to Sky Pia
[Music]
Skype year chapters 237 to 302 while I
believe I was able to talk about all the
things I wanted to enjoy a sky Pia is
the most intimidating thing I've had to
talk about so far apart from it
introducing some new technologies
complex corrupt political systems dozens
of new characters maybe some magic and
clues about Goldie Rogers past it also
happens to be the most complicated plot
in this series so far following three
separate groups as they weave their
stories in this greater narrative but in
very basic terms Skye Pia is what you
would get if you threw Dances with
Wolves Indiana Jones
Jack and the Beanstalk and a whole bunch
of Awesome writing into a blender that's
right Skye Pia is dances with Raiders of
the Lost Beanstalk Europe and from the
moment they shoot into the skies above
and land on the tangible clouds of the
sky lands the mystery surrounding the
area becomes immediately apparent
whether it be through being attacked
immediately by the natives protected by
a sky knight on a spotted Pegasus or
when they come across a check-in station
that charges an extortioner amount just
to enter and once we finally get into
this strange land the more we uncover
and the more questions we have what was
immediately apparent to me while reading
this section was the staggering level to
which this world in the sky has been
realized from their customs dress wear
and appearance to the wildlife
technology and terrain the entire world
of sky Pia is not only rich in mystery
but also feels as lived-in as any real
place in the real world perhaps the most
interesting inclusion in this era comes
in the form of the lands technology
called dials these dials come in various
types providing the wielders spectacular
power with electricity heat wind etc and
these aren't just a throwaway are tagged
on part of the story
Oda has gone to tremendous effort in
building the city's vehicles and combat
off sky Pia around these mechanisms
because if the civilization has this
technology of course it's going to be
built around it which is important as
they play a massive role in how this
story is told to and in the opening
chapters of their time spent in Sky Pia
they get taken in by two pleasant
individuals a girl named Connie's and
her father and while we have yet to
establish a concrete goal besides
exploring Skye Pia very soon the story
begins to show its hand as Nami Zorro
Robin and chopper are all apprehended on
behalf of the great comedy
the unquestioned ruler of this land and
without getting into too much detail
because good lore there's a lot of it
already the overall plot of the story
leads one half of the crew deep inside a
massive sacred forest where they must
atone for their crimes or something all
the while the other half tried to rescue
them and discover a massive corruption
within the land of sky Pia as they all
tremble in fear under this tyrant that
goes by the name of Qaumi in arrow and
this particular characters
characterization even before we meet him
is fantastic whether it be through the
locals their laws are those sent to
enforce those laws
the story begins painting a very serious
picture for us the reader through the
abuse political structure in this land
so right now we have achieved the first
goal of this arc find and regroup with
the other half of the straw hats that
were kidnapped and this is when the
story puts its foot on the accelerator
as we are not only going to follow just
these two straw head groups but two
other groups as this story unravels the
first of these main groups is a tribe of
people separated from the established
civilization we've been introduced to
already called sand Ian's clearly this
tribe takes inspiration from Native
American Mayan Incan and Aztec
traditions cultures and practices and
you bet Oda has fully realized their
clothing dialogue and motivation before
we even see them or know who they are
the two most important characters are
its leader Viper and a small child
called eisah who has mysterious powers
similar to many others on this land
called mantra an ability that allows her
and others that wield it to hear the
living beings of the greater area
pinpointing their locations however she
is by far the only person in this story
that has this ability and I will get
more into that later the final group I
want to talk about are the villains of
this community and his subordinates
known as vassals this sinister group of
villains is about to go to war with the
tribal group of sand Ian's very soon for
this sacred land and much like I said
they all have varying levels of mantra
power all with varying degrees of
success with some only being able to
hear in their immediate area and others
like an arrow being able to hear all
around them with no limits apparently
and with the introduction of this mantra
power in an arrow and ice ax with my
limited understanding of this ability it
seems to be amplified by the presence of
the earth and various people claimed to
be born with it but at various degrees
of proficiency so what I find
interesting was that the description of
this ability in this arc sounds a lot
like the strange thing that happened
during the fight with mr. one where he
could to hear everything or at least
significantly more than he was used to a
sort of zen-like state that for some
reason he couldn't tap into again so
what if this isn't something you were
born with but instead something you
either have an aptitude for or everyone
else can learn it that's just the
ongoing theory I have regarding mantra
that's hypothetical connection to Zorro
but I'm sure that would be touched on
later or disproven entirely but before
we get into that I want to thank surf
shark VPN for sponsoring today's video
in the ocean of online content there's a
lot of websites that take your info
without you even knowing it but you can
swim under their radar using surf shark
VPN with this particular service you can
stop websites from tracking your info
and setting targeted ads to you online
completely protecting your privacy
nothing is creepier than when you have a
conversation with a friend about
something and it pops up in your ads
plus with surf shark hard-luck ID
protection you even get an alert when
some Rando jerk is trying to break into
your email but one of my personal
favorite features of surf shark is that
you can see content that's not available
in your area for instance did you know
that right now in Netflix you can have
the first 130 episodes of one piece well
if you live in a country where that's
not available you can just login with
surf shark and you can get access to
that or any other show or film that that
isn't normally available for you so if
you want both freedom and protection
online click the link in the description
and use code TNM it not only gives you a
whopping 85 percent off the regular
price but also three months of service
totally for free surf shark also offers
a 30 day money-back guarantee so there's
no risk to even try it out for yourself
so if this service sounds interesting to
you or you want to support the channel
please check it out now back to the
video
[Music]
the sacred forest the apprehended straw
hats are eventually dragged to raised so
many red flags for me as unlike the vast
majority of what we've seen so far on
skype yet is still in direct contrast
with the wildlife that lurched within
the exceptionally large plant life and
unlike the rest of the land which is
erected under various types of dense
cloud formation this land stands on soil
see what I mean about this particular
story throwing so many different
mechanics and things to consider and I
haven't even mentioned the good stuff
yet once they orientate themselves Nami
Robin and Zorro off to get a fix on
their bearings leaving chopper to guard
the merry go which they were transported
in and while exploring the lush jungle
atop a tree
nami spots something that changes
everything she sees the second half of
that guy crickets house on the coast
it's at this moment we as an audience or
at least me get a sudden rush of insight
this island of soil floating in the sky
this was once part of Jaya and it was
sent flying up here four hundred years
ago and so it turns out that Nolan de
lyre was in fact telling the truth and
what's more is once Luffy who saw and
Sanji after encountering an defeating
one of a narrows vassals arrived back at
the ship to reconvene with the rest of
the group and in doing so Nami places
the map she has a jaya with the map
Luffy found of sky Pia and wouldn't you
know it they combine to make a skull
which means the right I must house
Eldorado the City of Gold the Sun reveal
of this half of a house and the
combination of these two maps was so
satisfying to me firstly because I
didn't see it coming and also because I
had all the clues necessary to solve
this beforehand but never did thanks to
the way ODIs set it up we've seen both
of these maps in isolation and we know
about the random nature and surge of
water that happens around this region
which means that between Nolan's first
and second arrivals on the island of
jaya the land must have been shot into
the sky removing El Dorado from the
island entirely the new goal now is to
find Eldorado and to take that gold but
the most interesting aspect of this
particular part of the story thread for
me is that the main conflict of this arc
isn't directly involving the straw hat
crew initially throughout this entire
series so far particularly every single
story directly involves at least one
member
all of the straw hats requiring rescue
or defense but this very arc the dated
conflict between the native tribes and
ian's fighting for their land against
the tyrannical and terrifying commie
enero and while he might not look
terrifying from the outset and bears a
striking resemblance to a particular
prolific rapper see if you can guess who
that is through his various
introductions with his subordinates and
his enemies he is by far the most
narcissistic and intimidating foe to
date wouldn't that not only imposes his
will on others before he takes them out
humiliates them demoralizes them and
stands before them as this
self-proclaimed invincible force that
cannot be resisted he firmly believes
he's a god and that everyone should
worship Him unsurprisingly his power of
electricity came from a devil fruit but
once again I am impressed by the level
of attention to detail Oda has
implemented here the story feels
entirely new as the straw hats
discovered this world and uncover its
secrets and what follows this decision
to search for and secure the secret city
of El Dorado is some of the most fun
I've ever had of reading a manga as I
mentioned earlier already the ludicrous
amount of story to cover in this
particular section would be a manic feed
fit for a madman and so to cut a long
story short the gang gets stood up and
slowly become involved in a war that's
taking place between the sand Ian's and
the forces of comedy in arrow there's a
really great scene that finally puts
into perspective how impossibly powerful
comic in a room is and essentially
during this parrot he gives the forces
of the natives five entire minutes of
uncontested free attacks just to prove
to them that their efforts are entirely
useless effectively in a row zaps from
area to area of the conflicts taking out
all of the rebel forces however in the
process the gang as well as Viper the
leader of the rebels take out all of the
subordinates of an arrow and Luffy sort
of gets lost in a giant silly snake but
eventually the fighting comes to a head
when the last men standing reached the
top of a vine that stretches through the
clouds and this is where the viper
character really comes into his own as
he shows us that he's had a plan of
attack
this entire time utilizing something I
hadn't heard mentioned for like a
hundred or so chapters he see prism
something that neutralizes the devil
free power within a user and in
combination with a reject dial he takes
out both himself and he narrow in the
prose
what a fantastic sequence I never saw
coming however something does happen
that's quite interesting during this and
I thought it worth mentioning bearing in
mind that this isn't at all a criticism
of the writing itself just a fun
observation I had in a row is now lying
motionless on the ground however using
his power he essentially shocks his
heart into working again much like a
defibrillator would in a hospital or on
those TV shows we see but did you know
that this scene is based on a myth
defibrillators do not in fact start the
heart beating again a shock to the heart
doesn't do that at all apparently in
fact it actually does the opposite
apparently defibrillators are used to
slow a person's Hired down and regulate
it the word tribulation means rapid
irregular beating of a heart and so a
defibrillator actually tries to restore
that back down to normal I can't exactly
blame ODA here decades of famous TV
shows tell us otherwise I just thought
it was a fun thing that was worth
mentioning and what's more interesting
is how Oda actually handles the
political struggle and mystery of Skype
use country and land the issues and
social commentary taking place in this
arc itself are actually quite
interesting and I love how older isn't
exactly taking a particular side in the
war either he acknowledges the unjust
means with which these people were
forced off of their land but he also
takes a little bit of time to draw
attention to the fact that the
great-grandchildren of Skye Pia
shouldn't have to pay for the sins of
their ancestors it's really interesting
as they consider this to be as much
their land as the natives do now leaving
the audience to choose their own side
now naturally we sympathize with the
natives much more as they had been
forced into this unnatural situation by
seemingly pure happenstance as tragedy
would have it and what makes this
situation all the more tragic is the
flashback sequence Oda gives us of
Nolan's story shedding light on the
encounter that paved the way for this
entire arc once again Oda doesn't feel
compelled to tell his story in a
conventional way or in a Russian manner
he sticks to his guns and spends what
would translate to over a month of manga
releases telling this crucial to
understand story of a Voyager and his
friends he made through unconventional
means in jaya essentially in a nutshell
Knowland a foreigner helps to save the
natives of a particular plague that is
befallen their island desperately trying
to help them in any way he can and after
several misunderstandings and a series
of unfortunate events the two leaders of
the respective sides gain respect and
love for one another unfortunately we
all know
this ends but the means with which it
does is hauntingly sad invoking from me
the strongest emotional response I've
had in this series so far the tribe
itself promised to ring the bell for
their friend to find them once again and
when Nolan returns they are gone having
been sent to Skype he and never see each
other ever again and the fight the tribe
leader puts up to ring that bell for his
friend is incredibly moving
I loved that flashback but what's most
interesting about it is echoed in a
quote Nico Robin made earlier in the arc
and how it ties in with the ending of
this story the quote is those that don't
respect history are doomed to repeat it
you see coming a route doesn't respect
anything let alone the legacy and
history of the natives even his
subordinates straight-out say this in
dialogue sometimes and so much like the
story of Noland Luffy a foreigner has
traveled to a new land in search of
adventure through misunderstandings he
comes into conflict with the natives
but eventually they recognize him as an
ally allowing Luffy to read these people
of a plague known as coming in a roo
that's ravaging the lands of sky Pia
threatening the people's very existence
the parallels between this story and
Dolan's are obvious but the way it ties
them together is nothing short of
masterful making this all the more
satisfying for me
[Music]
the final fight the planet near ruin axe
is perfectly in keeping with this
character up until this point and it's
fittingly grandiose in scale making for
a spectacular atmosphere in the final
fight of the act between Luffy himself
and as I mentioned a number of times so
far in a row has been built up as this
all-powerful invincible entity
impossible to hit impossible to
intimidate or to catch but he hasn't met
Luffy yet now granted while I did sort
of see this coming I absolutely adored
how it was handled not simply because of
the buildup in a row has received up
until now but because the mechanism with
which Luffy hit him made sense and my
favorite part it also makes complete
sense that in a row had never heard of
robber as a thing that ever existed
simply because where he comes from it
doesn't exist it's such a simple thing
but because it established earlier in
the story by way of them worshipping
anything that is sent from the ground up
to them it makes sense that they
wouldn't know robber even exists and so
in the form of the robber man Luffy
himself in a rune iäôs a natural enemy
and over the course of this fight Luffy
makes this God bow to his robbery powers
now naturally the fight is a lot more
complex than that incorporating some
ultra instinct by Luffy 20-some odd
years before Goku ever did as well as
his fists becoming trapped in a giant
golden bull which he uses to great
effect towards the end of the fight
turning a weakness into a strength
capping the arc off on the highest of
highs ringing the bell for the first
time in centuries it ringing so loud
that the descendant of Nolan himself
cricket on the shore of Gaea far below
can hear climaxing on one of the most
spectacularly touching images I've seen
from one piece so far a giant shadow of
Luffy casts over the horizon acting not
only as the Big Finish to the fight not
only as a signal to the people fire down
below that things are in hand but also
provides us an explanation as to why
Luffy and the gang saw Giants in the
ocean before hint it was the shadow cast
by the natives trapped in the sky
what an incredible story and what a
spectacular finish to what was for me
the single greatest adventure moon piece
has brought to me yet but that still
wasn't the most interesting Patra me I
think by firing away the most
interesting sections of this story are
told through the character of Nico Robin
who for the majority of the action
stayed out of harm's way
as she herself had more pressing matters
to attend to but before I get into that
one aspect of the character I've noticed
is how detached she seems to be in
situations and from those around her
despite having quite a few moments in
the arc where she helps save various
crew members in her own really cool ways
she also neglects to learn any of their
names and really is focused only on this
ultimate goal of her own to find and
read the punic lives and so for this
reason I believe she most definitely has
ulterior motives that the rest of the
crew aren't privy to and perhaps we
can't completely trust her yet so in a
sense I'm sort of with zoar on this one
but regardless the most interesting part
of the sky pure journey for me was the
ruins that she uncovered and decrypted
Robin reveals that there's a portion of
history that is completely unknown or
missing in the world and that's an
interesting thing to say but furthermore
realizes that on the top that she's
reading
Goldie Roger left a mark with another
character in Gant for reaffirming to her
that he had in fact been there 20 years
prior and what's perhaps the most
interesting things she says in this
instance is how did he know these
letters which begs me to ask who are
what is she does she know why she can
read these letters is her memory missing
is she connected in some way to Goldie
Roger
and what's more is that in this very
chapter to gain four points out that
Luffy was just like him I feel like at
this point they are trying to make me
think Roger is luffy's father but I have
a feeling that's not the case for some
reason it seems perhaps to telegraphed
and what's more is that the text on
these punna glyphs from alabasta and no
skype you have both alluded to a
powerful weapon but both have given that
weapon a different name and perhaps
there's two weapons who knows to find
out more about this I suppose we have to
wait and see how this develops as they
find more of these moving forward and
finally Robin declares that she will
have to connect them all and reach the
end of the ground line so it looks like
she has a goal now to match the rest of
her crew but apart from that now that
the sky piarc is in the books I'd like
to give some predictions I have moving
forward in this video I mentioned that
the mantra mechanic might be huge
moving forward and that I think people
can learn it like Zorro might have done
in the art prior I also think see prisms
might have a very interesting future too
I wonder if someone who has a devil
fruit power if you were to hold a sea
prism would that person be able to float
or swim know that the devil fruit powers
have been negated and finally gol D
Roger given what I knew at the very
beginning of this story when they said
he was executed I didn't really think
anything of it but now that I understand
the earth-shattering scope of power
these villains in this series have I
feel like apprehending gol D Roger who
was the king of all of the Pirates and
executing him would be an impossible
thing to do unless it was his decision
so for that reason I believe he's still
alive and that perhaps sometime in the
future Robin will find one of those
markings Roger left behind on one of
those Potter glyphs I have no idea how
these things are going to unwind moving
forward but I'm ridiculously excited to
see how everything shapes up but that'll
do for this week I've been to lis not
mark I'll see you all next time and
thank you so much for watching
[Music]